[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le coût réel des cartes de crédit ce
soir andréanne les canadiens ont
plusieurs reproches à faire à adresser
aux émetteurs de cartes de crédit
wei un sondage la firme jd power qui
révèle aujourd'hui que même si les
canadiens ont moins dépensé avec leur
carte de crédit au printemps il y en a
quand même le quart 6 24% général des
canadiens qui ont pas été en mesure de
faire leurs paiements ou tous leurs
paiements sur leurs cartes de crédit
depuis le début de la pandémie c'est
énorme alors 24% et dans ce sondage losc
on apprend aussi c'est que ce même si de
manière générale la satisfaction envers
les cartes de crédit est resté stable
il ya quand même plusieurs reprochent au
haut niveau de sens à la clientèle en
particulier si on voulait parler à
quelqu'un parce qu'on voulait avoir des
informations sur les assouplissements
possible c'était très long peu de
communication aussi c'est ce qui a été
relevé dans ce sondage pour dire que de
manière générale il ya toujours à peu
près 30 % des canadiens qui ne paient
pas tous leurs soldes de cartes de
crédit atteint le sol de moyens de cette
manière là au canada sur cartes de
crédit 4326 dollars c'est quand même
assez élevé imaginé avec un taux
d'intérêt qu'il s'est souvent autour de
20%
soleure 20% pour les cartes de crédit et
ce aussi en moyenne à parce que quand le
manqué un paiement souvent il ya des
pénalités on peut augmenter le taux sur
votre carte de crédit ça peut même
atteindre 30 % ça commence à faire cher
alors quand on ne fait que le paiement
minimum par exemple à chaque mois ça
nous coûte une fortune
c'est énorme je vous ai fait une petite
simulation si vous avez un seul par
exemple de 3000 $ sur votre carte de
crédit que vous ne payez que le paiement
minimum ses 2 % donc 60 $ pour les
premiers paiements
ça va vous prendre 54 ans 54 millions là
tu 54 ans pour rembourser si vous ne
faites que le paiement minimum à chaque
mois ce qui vous donnera en 54 ans des
intérêts payés sur votre sol de 13000 46
dollars pour une dette sur cartes de
crédit je le rappelle de 3000 $ alors
c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
toujours important lorsqu on peut se le
permettre de payer son solde ou de
trouver d'autres façons de rembourser sa
carte de crédit et de transférer
c'est d'ailleurs à peu pris la pire des
temps uniquement avec les taux
d'interaction si élevé voilà merci merci
beaucoup andré